[Music]
hi I'm chance I'm playing a show in
Tampa tomorrow night and I want all
those hearty caring and death in the
Tampa area there's a commonality see our
show
sad family who by the route they're
always entertaining for a dram and
chance way that they watching and you
got what that I never seen an
interpretation happen like that before
we just want to try not and then you
look at the deaf community right yo we
have like our own rapidly moving that go
athlete but he's signing - okay this is
it - my name is Mack nasty on the video
creators founder definitely dope during
a hip hop I mean with interpreters well
outside that knowing and the juju is
standard if I made would entertain your
mission is to really make sure that the
audience who's never really experienced
listening to music can fear in a way
that they can relate to it with a
language but they can also understand it
in its own context without it being
blurred or
you know somebody say turn up at the
club I think of how he looked in the car
people are good let's go so I'm thinking
that how I would define or show what you
mean to turn up to cut it by fine turn
up it doesn't look the same it doesn't
have the same effect compared to it back
there
turned up imitation DNA in abomination
[Music]
I doubt my hearing aids another tooth
though I've always had getting a whole
time growing up college when I was 18 my
first time really starting to learn hip
hop back with like my heart left to just
try to practice on my own that I could
keep up with regular conversation and
then I'm good right okay fine and
tolling is easier to and then people
would see me sign Thunder it'd be like
oh that's cool
there's providing hip-hop music to
another coach that I never really had
the chance to experience it before
there's nothing out there to really feel
included why not create something to
where people can feel included and not
just be back
[Music]
[Music]
whenever people tell us mariachi music
is sacred and you can't change it or
touch it you know and believe me there's
a lot of people that are trying to
convince us like what we're doing is
like a musical sin but in order to
create something known beautiful you
have to take risk you have to do
something no however something new come
about if you don't change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
metallurgy is the first and only
heavy-metal mariachi band in the world
we know we're doing when it comes to
mariachi if we're metallurgy everybody
spent years doing mariachi we're Charles
we did mariachi for our life that's how
we made money we use traditional
mariachi instruments it's the same thing
that you would find in a in a mariachi
band doing what we do is not really that
easy to make a heavy metal song into a
metal achi song you have to invent
rhythm and we basically create patterns
and a lot of people don't see it they're
already here like oh wow that's a new
pattern but that thing is is that we see
people moving to it then we know we did
a good job
[Music]
we cover a lot of different types of
events and everything like something you
guys know my cousin roses
[Music]
Ozzy Osbourne
our core stuff like Slayer not so hard
her stuff like journey huh you name it
with water
there's times where a song translates
very well and we can pick it up like in
a couple hours we can put something
together and sounds really nice
[Music]
we've even traveled to Mexico to go play
over there and not really knowing how
they would accept it because there's a
lot of people that are very traditional
you know they love it because my tea
actually music isn't my life it's about
beauty so heavy metal music and they're
actually singing about the same stuff
they just do it in their own different
way
[Music]
by innovating the two things we're
showing my TIG people this music is also
beautiful but there's no heavy metal
music is that your music could be
interpreted a different way you know I
think we like that message that's being
sent out my name is peril wolf and I am
the lead singer songwriter for the band
peril and we are an all-girl Hasidic
rock band and Crown Heights Brooklyn all
of our live concerts are for women only
I grew up in a Hasidic home so having a
separation of the sexes in certain
places is pretty common there's a law in
Judaism for men not to listen to the
singing voice of a woman who is not an
immediate family member
[Music]
I would say one of the biggest
misconceptions that people have about
the Hasidic community people think that
women are totally oppressed that women
can't be leaders I felt very much
empowered as a woman spending time with
other powerful women and having time to
connect and having our own space women
deserve a space to rock out the response
from the solicita community has been
really positive mostly you know let's
let's empower women let's make something
new for women when fans come over and
tell you I felt so comfortable tonight I
felt like I could dance I felt like I
could be myself or I really felt a
powerful energy being around other women
I'm like okay we're doing something
important and that's really all that
matters
[Music]
we have been called Indians in a
hallucination
tribal music club music mixed together
and made by these guys
I'm DJ Indian I'm tool man I'm bear
witness and we are a tribe called red
[Music]
weari mix traditional powwow music with
contemporary club music First Nations
powwow music originated in the North
American Plains traditionally consists
of a large drum with singers and dancers
around it essentially follow music
traditional dance music that's why we
ended up doing what we do we're using
our music now in much the same way that
Pao always used to create a gathering
place
[Music]
and to A Tribe Called red powwow music
isn't just an adopted style it's a
significant part of their heritage
I'm Anishinabe from Nipissing First
Nations I grew up around powwows and
going to powwow is there big cultural
gatherings the significance of us using
powwow in our music is just a way to
create something that represents
indigenous people and that indigenous
people can relate to their shows are a
cultural fusion experience combining
more than just sound but visuals - we
ended up hooking up with some people who
were doing the same thing we were doing
with dance there are native dance crew
there breakers but they mix it with
power so it's that same kind of fusion
and it's that combination of
contemporary and tradition that's
introducing indigenous culture to a
wider audience I think when we started
if you ask your average non-indigenous
person in Canada if there is no what
problem as it was they would shrug and
say no now I think that's begun to
change
[Music]
people sometimes here in the US stinks
cabins died but it grew in other parts
of the world and then it leaked back
into the Latin ska bands that we have in
LA
[Music]
most people in the rest of the world
don't expect Latinos in LA to listen to
Scout music or even know about it but
it's what we do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Clement Therese I'm a
musician producer I'm most of the guy
behind the biggest ska punk events we
have in LA I grew up running around in
the streets of Linwood Compton and South
Gate I got shot at a few times I got
mugged a few times if I didn't have
music and I didn't have the ska punk
shows to go to I don't know where I
would have been Latin ska punk has
influences from all over the place it's
a genre that collects bits and pieces of
everything from Jamaican reggae to
hardcore to the Mexican Latin Scott it's
just a clash of everything
Latin ska started popping up in LA in
the mid late 90s it was in the
neighborhood we had a hard time playing
legitimate venues that's kind of what
sparked me having to organize some of
these events because no one would do it
for us I think a lot of these Latino
kids in the neighborhoods are attracted
to ska music the way people dance the
way people dress they just find
themselves in that the rhythm really
gets you going it touches a lot of
people so a lot of these kids that go to
our shows it helps them find themselves
it makes them feel like they do belong
to something it's a very personal
connection to them
[Music]